[Music]
hey guys we are so excited to announce
we are producing our own original
content head over to the trendy for the
best DIYs fashion tips makeup acts and
so much more we are sure you're going to
love it and be sure to let us know what
you think in the comment section hear
from you cartoon lovers always come up
with fan fictions that combine two very
different cartoon worlds together but
there are several cartoons out there
that actually made that happen and it's
totally awesome stick around to see
spongebob cameos and one of the most
popular modern Nickelodeon cartoons
don't forget to subscribe to our Channel
and give this video a big thumbs up if
you're a fan of any of these cartoons
now let's check 10 best cartoon
crossovers and cameos Teen Titans go and
Powerpuff Girls in 2016
Teen Titans go aired a very special
episode that brought back childhood
memories for everyone who used to enjoy
watching movies on Cartoon Network if
you've missed it
you absolutely have to see episode 40 of
season 3 called ttg vs. PPG Teen Titans
go vs the Powerpuff Girls if you think
about it the Powerpuff Girls were almost
like Teen Titans go in a way both shows
had adorable characters for the super
powers both shows were hilarious and
both had interesting cameos with
characters from other cartoons in TTG
versus PPG mojo dojo plans to take over
the world in jump City he's followed by
the Powerpuff Girls who then compete
against the Teen Titans go for the best
superhero team who won you'll have to
watch the episode to find out one of our
favorite moments was when blossom and
Robin had to find out where mojo was
hiding Robin found a note and went
through a great extent to search for any
possible clues on mojo's location while
blossom just read the text and realized
he was at the zoo
we also found it hilarious that Beast
Boy and Cyborg thought Mojo Jojo was
actually pretty cool for a talking
monkey if you think about it his outfit
makes him fit in the Teen Titans go
world just perfectly the girls
definitely brought a lot of attitude to
the show the Jetsons and the Flintstones
if you were born after the year 2000
you've probably completely missed the
Cartoon Network era of the Jetsons as
well as watching the Flintstone
on Saturday mornings here's a super
quick lowdown on both cartoons The
Flintstones and the Jetsons were
produced by the same animation studio
hanna-barbera one first aired in 1960s
and the other in 1962 one was a show
about living in the Stone Age and the
other was a futuristic cartoon with
flying space cars and robots the shows
were so popular hanna-barbera producers
decided to do a crossover movie in 1987
it's hard to believe that this would
even work but it did the characters who
had to run to use their car met the
family that was practically flying more
than they were walking it's a time
travel experiment that has gone wrong
through the Jetsons family but it
actually went right in so many other
ways the futuristic family ends up in
the past instead of the 25th century and
ends up meeting the Flintstones but
would Rosie the robot maid built a time
machine retriever and manages to bring
back the wrong family basically it's a
huge time machine mess but an excellent
movie that's worthy of your time
everyone makes an appearance including
astro and dino the two pets we'd never
think would be seen together we're
telling you it's a must watch movies
Scooby Doo and Johnny Bravo cartoon
crossovers used to be a lot more
frequent than they are today no one's
quite sure why but we're very grateful
we were able to see different universes
unite one of the weirdest combinations
that actually worked really well with
scooby-doo and Johnny Bravo the two
cartoons are completely different from
each other but in 1997 scooby-doo aired
a very special episode it's called
Bravo dooby doo and it's the third
episode of season 1 the plot is pretty
simple
Johnny Bravo ends up getting help from
the scooby-doo help because he needs to
find his missing aunt they meet when his
car breaks down in the similar setting
we usually see in scooby-doo one of the
best moments in the series is when
Johnny stays true to his lady's main
character and continuously tries to
flirt with Daphne at the same time Velma
desperately tries to win Johnny Bravo's
attention the episode includes some
innuendos such as Johnny offering a
Scooby Snack to Daphne
after he asks her if she wants to get
lost with him we're glad daphne wasn't
impressed as we all know that the only
true relationship goals of the series
are Freddy and Daphne and we wouldn't
have it any other way we have to admit
that Johnny Bravo did bring a
of comedy into scooby-doo along with his
infamous terrible pick-up lines Rugrats
and The Wild Thornberrys if you're a fan
of the Rugrats and you haven't seen this
crossover you absolutely have to it's
one of the most adorable movies we have
ever seen
we love the Rugrats but do you remember
the Wild Thornberrys the cartoon follows
the lives of a nomad family that films
documentaries the show features a
character with one of the best powers
were extremely jealous of Eliza can
communicate with animals meanwhile the
Rugrats is about a group of toddlers and
their silly adventures you'd never think
these two cartoons would ever mix but
they did in 2003 Nickelodeon movies
produced Rugrats go wild a movie that
features the popular cartoon toddlers
going on an adventure through the safari
and ended up stranded on an island
because their cruise ship flipped over
with Rugrats as the leading characters
the movie is totally adorable and worth
seeing if you haven't had a chance to
watch you get how could you not want to
watch 80 minutes of Rugrats teaming up
with the Thornberrys after meeting them
on an uninhabited island and just to
give you a quick spoiler
this whole thing is Stu's fault don't
question the storyline remember it's all
part of a toddler's imagination however
the movie is definitely adorable and we
can never get enough of Rugrats cute
baby talk American Dad king of the hill
and Family Guy usually crossovers only
involved one other alternative universe
because well it's easier for animators
to figure out how to merge the two
worlds but this amazing crossover is
possibly one of the best ones yet
American Dad king of the hill and Family
Guy all have a few things in common
along with being comedy shows they're
also extremely satiric when it comes to
portraying American life so imagine
seeing all those characters in a single
episode the episode is called big fat
and it's the seventeenth episode of the
eleventh season of Family Guy the
episode opens with an intro which
involves king of the hill characters and
it's entirely done in the show style the
actual episode has to do with the
Griffins
visiting the Smiths from American Dad
who are also their new neighbors in the
true family dad's style things get
pretty complicated as you can imagine we
won't spoil anything for you but we can
say that it's one of the best cartoon
episodes we have ever seen fans that
love all of these shows
completely mind blown by this crossover
and it left them and us wanting more we
still can't get over seeing all of them
together one of the best lines from the
episode happens when Peter Griffin
laughs at Stan Smith that he's a classic
American dad he sure is Adventure Time
and Futurama by now you've probably
figured out that a lot of crossovers
share the same plot most of the time
something happens that transports the
characters into a different cartoon
world
well this crossover is a little bit
different when it was first announced
that Jake and Finn were making an
appearance in Futurama the fans of both
Emmy award-winning shows went totally
insane
you can find the mini crossover in a
Futurama episode called Leela and the
gene stock the actual reasons behind
Jake and Finn's appearance on the show
are still unclear but we have to admit
that this is one of our absolute
favorite crossovers the entire scene
lasts for just under nine seconds but
it's totally rewarding we see bender
meeting Jack and Finn in the tower where
they are hanging on the wall presumably
trapped
Jake asks bender what's the time and
Bender replies that is time for him to
shut up here's another fun crossover
vendor is actually voiced by the same
after as Jake so technically he's
telling himself to shut up
talk about a mind-blowing crossover
you'd never think that these two shows
could actually come together but then
again anything is possible in Futurama
which cartoon world would you want to
pair up with Futurama let us know in the
comments the loud house and Fairly
OddParents the loud house is one of the
most popular cartoon shows of 2016 and
2017 if you've been our subscriber for a
long time you know how much we love this
crazy show having the family with eleven
children definitely isn't easy but
imagine when one of your kids opens up a
portal to the world of The Fairly
OddParents
it's a recipe for an amazing episode and
it's called The Fairly OddParents meets
the loud house what makes this episode
even more special is that only the
original characters from Fairly
OddParents appear in the actual
storyline the plot is actually pretty
fun lissa loud she's only four years old
but she's still the smartest in the
family works on an experiment that
opened up a portal to dimmsdale
maincity of The Fairly OddParents the
same portal is also found by Timmy and
curiosity makes the iconic characters
meet we won't spoil the episode for you
any longer
you'll just have to see it but we could
promise that it's one of the most
hilarious madhouse episodes ever make
sure you keep on watching our video
because there's one more crossover from
the rod house fans would absolutely love
to see trust us once you see what it is
you'll want it to happen too but first
let's check out a few other awesome
crossovers the grim adventures of Billy
and Mandy and the Powerpuff Girls the
grim adventures of Billy and Mandy was
arguably one of the best and possibly
the weirdest shows on Cartoon Network
the show follows the lives of the two
siblings Billy and Mandy and the grim
reaper who's pretty much forced to hang
out with the kids who showed in a
crossover with the Powerpuff Girls and
it's one of the oddest concepts ever the
episode is called Mifare Mandy and it's
the fifteenth episode of season 5 the
double length episode first starts off
with a little Miss scurvy beauty-pageant
when Mandy finally sings on the day of
the talent show the crowd loves it which
causes the usually grumpy Mandy to smile
as a result this makes the world implode
and the characters are transported into
the city of Townsville also known as the
home of the Powerpuff Girls
basically Billy Mandy and the grim
reaper transformed into the Powerpuff
Girls and it's the weirdest thing ever
Grimm becomes blossom mandy becomes
bubbles and billy
is buttercup and it seems like no one is
really enjoying this new dimension one
of our favorite moments from the episode
is seeing them flying to the city and
grim saying they will never talk about
this again
the scene was short but it did make us
laugh once again the day was saved
thanks to Billy Mandy and Grimm the
citizens and Family Guy seeing the
crossover between American Dad king of
the hill and Family Guy was already
fascinating but Family Guy also paired
up with the Simpsons the episode was
called The Simpsons guy and it's the
first episode of season 13 if you're a
fan of both shows this episode was
extremely mind-blowing to see the story
talks about the Griffin family clean for
safety after one of his comic books
becomes viral on the Internet and not in
a good way the
ends up being stranded in Springfield
and they stop by the donut store where
they meet Homer who and true homer style
teaches them how to really eat donuts we
then get to see both families hang out
and one of our favorites is seeing Bart
together with Stewie one of our favorite
moments is when Bart introduces Stewie
to his weapons closet and it turns out
to be a collection of slingshots and
other kid toys and let's not forget
about them prank calling Moe's Tavern
Lisa and Meg also make an interesting
pair and we love that Lisa encourages
Meg that she matters after all even
though she thinks she's not good at
anything well she does end up being good
at something but you'll have to watch
the episodes to see what it is let's
just say Lisa wasn't happy about it the
loud house and spongebob the loud house
was inspired by a lot of popular
characters and it looks like the
creators have a crossover relationship
with SpongeBob SquarePants there were so
many spongebob references on the show we
could make a whole video about it
they're so well hidden we'd bet you've
missed most of them but here are just a
few that caught our eyes in season 1
episode 1 you can catch the loud sisters
fighting over a remote but what was
actually playing on the TV with
SpongeBob SquarePants well at least we
can assume it was considering it
featured a much simplified version with
a yellow square and a star-shaped
character Lisa loud skin the garden
class also shows a picture of what it
looks like to be spongebob characters
since the loud house already teamed up
with the world of The Fairly OddParents
fans are asking to collodion for a
crossover with SpongeBob SquarePants can
you imagine how wacky that episode might
be we can't wait to see it characters
like Lisa and Lucy might not have a lot
of tolerance for the happy-go-lucky
spongebob but we bet he'd fit right in
with a loud family
come on Nickelodeon let's make it happen
what do you think would happen in a
crossover between the loud house and
SpongeBob SquarePants let us know in the
comments and we'll pin the craziest
suggestion that's it for talking about
the best cartoon crossovers and cameos
want more check out five ridiculous
examples of cartoon logic that will make
you facepalm and get ready to facepalm a
lot see you around
[Music]